[Music]
nestled in the heart of Scenic New
England lies the small industrial town
of Southbridge Massachusetts
it's home to the Vienna Inn and
Restaurant husband and wife Jonathan and
Lisa crock have owned and operated in
since buying the property back in the
year 2000.
Jonathan had this crazy idea of creating
the Vienna
as an Austrian restaurant and bed and
breakfast she said have you been
drinking
no not yet
we try to transport people and to give
them that feeling of being in Vienna
without having to fly there
[Music]
people come in and they stay here for
the first time they think that Jonathan
and Lisa are very gracious host Charming
the perfect married couple but if you
dig a little bit deeper and you stay a
little bit longer find out it's quite a
different story Lisa is an emotional
person she does get upset often she will
just you know explode and she can't help
but be upset she's over the top
[Music]
my beautiful wife
my boss sometimes she's not so nice to
me why do you always have to dress like
a goddamn like bomb there has been a
time where I called her a psycho [__]
because she was being a psycho [__]
clean up yeah wait I'm done with this I
don't feel like Lisa is authentic when
she's crying I don't feel like she ever
means it
[Music]
Jonathan and Lisa live in a room at the
end you can hear them screaming at each
other and you can hear it in the dining
room so there's no boundaries they'll
come down after the shift at the end of
the night and they'll have cigars have
some drinks the environment can quickly
become unprofessional she'll go up to a
table and ask them about like their sex
lives you are good looking we don't get
that many locals at the Vienna there's
like a lot of things that people think
in town about the Vienna and I think
it's become a little taboo
you have those rumors going around
people say oh the Vienna they're all
swingers it's a big brothel it's just
it's just ridiculous it's ridiculous
that being said we're very friendly
people
very friendly
[Music]
people from the outside think that
Vienna is doing very well and we're very
prosperous but somewhere in there we're
losing they're dragging us down with
them and if they want us to help them
they they need to help us
the Vienna is our home has been for 13
plus years
and you know it's hanging by a thread
[Music]
um
and this 5 30 at table five you're
walking right in we want to be ready for
it
to this place oh my God
what happened to him
he didn't last very long did he he found
our cat
oh bloody hell dead cat my cabbage isn't
that funny
hello welcome
nice to meet you always good to see you
too Gordon first name is Melissa Melissa
good morning how are you how are you
Lisa Croc Lisa nice to seeing you don't
look very happy I do
it's my resting face wow um yes welcome
to the Vienna I'm so happy to be here
welcome to the cat
[Laughter]
and you got it stuffed for Halloween
right
actually better to see you now right um
yeah
I love the attire by the way
thank you
everyone wears this wow how much are the
outfits about 300 400 300 average you
know they get their own I mean they're
their own dresses you know oh you buy
your own uniforms yes we do stop it we
do well they have them for many years
and it reminds them to not gain weight
wow so who designed the place well my
husband and I and whose idea was it to
buy it
um my husband so it wasn't yours it was
not my idea actually very much against
it wow uh why were you against it it was
very overwhelming I had two small
children but probably uh after I lost my
mind the first year
I think we started to get a hang of it
and who's Austrian are you from my
husband's half Austrian or in Polish
right I'm not nearly as exotic I'm very
American right and he's the chef right
so he runs the restaurant kitchen and
you run the Inn correct
and whose idea was the violins on the
table mine where did that come from that
was actually from an estate sale down
the street a dead man's violin yeah why
not
I don't want to sit across the table
with my wife and look at a dead man's
violin well a bit freaky now I don't
know what would you rather look at when
you see the Vienna huh who's her my wife
oh your wife yes but you have to have
something to make up that white space
what would you suggest my wife you're
gonna put her on the table that's kind
of scandalous I'm so [__] confused
Dead Man's violin what about some
flowers
bloody hell is this place always as
clustered as this
and who's that there a Prussian family
of course that was Friedrich that their
family always murdered
I'm so hungry yes wow so dead man's
violin and murder on the wall and great
story to encourage a nice warm welcoming
dinner
so um why don't I check in upstairs you
can do that right now yes please thank
you
wow interesting indeed she has a clutter
your bedroom's over here rocking chair
where's that from that's actually the
first piece I ever refinished wow
so you're quite an Antiques holder
room service oh room service come in
holy mackerel now what we have here is
some pulled boar yes right and then you
have a little celery right on top wow
and what's that it's a little parsley
excellent
um well take one would you like me to
have one yeah cools there's three three
pieces okay excellent yeah
thank you thank you for sharing you're
welcome hold on wait wait let me put a
little bit of the garnish on there you
want me to have that but yeah we'll have
a little PCS
mm-hmm
what did you think of that by the way
celery we really don't like it
the pull board maybe just a bit more
salt
wow and what did you think of that I
think it's a nice little surprise for
people when they come in to uh liven up
their appetite ball was very watery it
was very watery and the bread was soggy
soaking wet from the celery root thank
you enjoy your stay
please pass on my comments to the chef I
definitely will
here we go
oh dear okay wow and who designed these
bedrooms I designed everything
you design I well papered it as well
seriously
what's this that's a another closet I
don't have a closet in my bedroom that's
a closet that we have because there's an
area over here for guests to use but
where am I going to hang my clothes
right over here
oh
need an entire closet so if you need
clothes out of your closet you come in
my bedroom do you have the key on you I
do can I see inside I'm just I'm a bit
free with locked doors in my bedroom
yeah I'm sorry thank you it's right here
oh it's there
wow
just my closet
holy crap stop it stop it seriously all
my stuff
it's like a garage sale in a closet
that's why we keep a lock on it well
I've got no interest in wearing any of
the garments but thank you are you sure
I'm I'm positive 100 positive bloody
hell what's the price of this room this
one is 220. 220 dollars yeah
and I have to share my wardrobe with the
owner
if it was through this room here well
that actually goes to my bedroom so do
you just walk in when you need to get
some clothes from here no but from your
bedroom to my bedroom well I only do
that once or twice a week
it's an antique purse that was actually
found in the house and we thought it was
really neat to be able to help that's
for that's a toothbrush holder in case
you decide to take it along with you
that's a toothbrush hole or you could
stick tampons in there if you really
wanted to
we do usually have those oh they're not
in there right now there you go an old
lady's case I'm just trying to think of
clever ideas to make this feel like a
historican
Stark it's definitely historic oh
bloody how how old is that you need that
now it's just fascinating to see what's
in my basket thank you for that oh dear
everything looks dated I mean First
Impressions it looks very very tired
what is all that somebody wants to throw
roses on the bed ah go on sake isn't
that adorable and then they go back in
the drawer I guess once you've used them
foreign
look forward to seeing you downstairs
I'll have lunch thank you you're welcome
that's freaky the owner's bedroom is
literally a meter away the place is so
dated what a mess
all right it's just cluttered what a
mess
look at this
I mean seriously
bloody hell packed with [__] everywhere
decoration
right here thank you
so whatever you prefer boom boom boom
let's get some food you want to get some
food out yeah
Jesus Lisa
junk everywhere
yeah I know everywhere
is the whole house packed like this of
course it is it's crazy have you always
been this bad it's a new thing I'm
coming at terms with nice it's just uh
but you do have a problem with that
actually no I I think I've actually
gotten rid of a lot of things in the
past couple years don't have a problem
with everything I've just seen in the
last 10 minutes wow hello
right let's uh oh geez
um do you know how to say all these how
did you pronounce that
um you've been here a long time
a lot of people must point to what they
want to order right or just pick up the
last line how do you pronounce that
corning's burger clubs wow and how long
has this menu been running like this uh
since the beginning oh 13 years ago
seriously yes let's start off with go
for the scallops okay let's do the beer
batter the sauerkraut yeah let's go for
that
um and throw the vegetarian mushroom
ravioli in as well wonderful okay great
I'll keep hold of the menu for now okay
thank you sear it in first
whoa yeah almost lost it regroup regroup
where is Missy I'll bring it right out
Mr Ramsay's first red pepper for Blanc
yes sir
our seared diver scallops with a red
pepper Blanc wow thank you and scallops
are normally round right yes they are we
have beautiful sea scallops I'm not sure
why they cut it up today ah no am I oh
well excellent okay thank you very much
looks like the dogs chewed them I mean
seriously
what's up with that one excuse me would
you like me to give me any comments back
to the show comments yeah no [__] thank
you terrible
we'll have Val take care of it for you
who's Val me I like the way you talk
about yourself in the third person Seer
diver scallops tastes like [__] tastes
like [__] really wow okay any specific
kind of [__] or is this no diarrhea
these here are the
sauerkraut and bhaktig
and are these are edible flowers or not
they are chrysanthemums yeah okay great
thank you all right
hmm
there it is
they are terrible I mean the food is so
dated it's extraordinary
like a pair of camels bollocks
hmm
this I have here is the mushroom crepes
and cream well
there she is wow
wow yes delicious
I mean you're kidding me no no I'm
[__] delicious seriously really good
no the flowers I'm all about ah you had
me going there for the whole second I
thought it was all about the food I I
maybe next course Jonathan the flowers
are absolutely delicious the flowers
and this menu doesn't change every
decade it's the same menu it's been on
for 13 years jonathaniel dishes oh sorry
I asked you a question at least all
these answers go on you Jonathan doesn't
change I'm sorry you you answered
Melissa's question first then I'll go
back to Melissa you said this doesn't
change but once a decade and I said
Jonathan doesn't change much right
um you've been here a long time
you use the place
um what's the big issues here a little
disorganization
um things aren't clear yeah nothing
consistent yeah and you know one puts
the other on edge and we get the brand
end of it
police is listening to every word you're
saying
I can barely hear you
no no I was just talking to Mr
do whatever you need
Ed um what's the worst thing she's ever
done to you uh smack me on the back of
the head and in front of the customers
seriously
in front of the customer not hard but
demeaning
yeah
oh damn so there was under seasoned over
season under seasoned failure which
everything
wow
um where's Lisa I will grab her for you
right away Mr Gordon and grab Jonathan
too as well will you please I will go
yeah and anyone else in the kitchen
please okay
excuse me Lisa Jonathan yes can we meet
up in front with Gordon
that's the most edible thing in here
uh right
um First Impressions I look outside
historic Inn
unfortunately you've misspelled that
it's prehistoric everything's so dated I
go up to the room and the room's shoddy
Jonathan do you not think it's a bit
weird that a my door's open adjacent to
your bedroom but your wife's clothes are
in my closet
I never thought of it that way but I
guess that is that's weird
that was shocking
he's just certainly one of the worst
lunches I've ever eaten
and it was that bad I started eating the
edible flowers
you can't be proud of what you've just
served me and charged me absolutely not
you're correct you clearly have given up
it tastes like it and it feels like it
what do you think we should do clothes
because your heart's not in it
and I think your head's just in with the
clouds
embarrassing
pretty [__] awful
it sucked
caught me off guard completely I mean
you knew he was coming I did
really embarrassing
I really thought we
tried harder and
I'll let you down I'm sorry you did let
me down I'm really sorry
I always try to tell you that we need to
change things we need to make them
sexier and you never want to listen to
me
I've always wanted to change and you
always say I'm too random and it's not
I'm not random I'm trying to show you
ideas and things that we can do
differently
it sucks he couldn't have cooked worse
than he did can you pull my ankle it
hurts so much I'm never gonna be able to
walk tonight oh God
don't worry about it we'll be fine we'll
figure something out it doesn't [__]
listen to me does he oh I feel so good
I'm not really that upset I'm just
crying because I want to right now I've
heard rumors around town that the
basement is known as a swingers hangout
and is used for late night parties so
before dinner service I want to take a
look at what's downstairs
look at this
my God
some really expensive stuff this is this
is crazy I can't believe how much stock
there is here
it's not just spending the money in all
the wrong places
look at that this place goes on and on
oh my God
please shout before entering the mineral
spa
mineral spa
oh my God
this is like a dungeon dungeon for
swingers
tonight is crucial because I need to get
my eyes on how Jonathan and Lisa are
running the hotel since both of them
seem to be on different pages can I get
your beverages to start with we're
getting some wine okay I was thinking
Cosmos but mine
there's so much stuff in here I've never
seen a kitchen so cluttered it's been
worse believe it or not
how come the food just sits there right
at the moment our timing is really not
at all good what are these for Jonathan
those are little pre meals a little
crackers little pieces of cheese
pre-meals
I give it to you get rid of it please to
get rid of yeah trash oh you can't serve
that oh that's a paper for customers to
eat you can't ask them to dip into a
[__] doily with a cracker and then a
flowering and yum yum yum yum it's just
no it's a bit [__] up Jimmy it's not
your place but it's just a bit weird
you okay yeah no I'm fine I'm okay when
were the chickens roasted
two days ago that's the last of them
why do we roast them two days in advance
they're delivered twice a week they're
cooked off the delivery there what kind
of impression do you think you're
sending out to your customers when that
chicken's roasted two days before they
come I I I
hours
when did you think this chicken was
roasted
oh my goodness I hope it was today it
was roasted two and a half days ago
that was going to be dry as a dog's bone
but anyway uh try to enjoy okay
they've been coming for 12 years you
need to seriously just focus on getting
this night done and they sit there all
schmuck I want to kick them out right
now do you want us to take the food back
I mean this is like so disappointing
that you guys feel this way I thought we
were friends and I I thought you would
have maybe told us if you felt the food
sucked that much you know it's really
gosh I feel I feel like I want to pass
out right now
um so the lady was just talking to her
had no idea how chicken was roasted two
and a half days ago
roasted two and a half days ago yeah I
didn't know that okay fine it's not my
business with him
two are so defensive there's a thousand
different ways to make stress
not to do it I'm talking about the
chicken I'd love to find out the
pressure chicken I'm talking about the
chicken
make an excuse again
nothing resonates with you does it
nothing it certainly does it actually it
all does
what
and how I just wanted to keep it
together tonight that's all
you're crazy
I'm manic yes I am right now
how's it going guys uh something between
shitty and awful what does it mean when
you feel like an elephant sitting on
your chest oh you don't have a heart
are you hungry Gordon what is this
that is bacon should be on a different
shelf and this yeah that shouldn't be
thrown there either
beer batter for the beer battered shrimp
should be thrown out
and this one let me just stab that on
top put it right on top
what is all this
that was
bacon no no okay now why is it in your
fridge like this I dropped it one shelf
below instead of putting where it
belonged I put it on the corner normally
these things are pretty orderly this is
a complete cluster book
and what's that
RV
let's
what is going on
the whole operation is screwed the
kitchen shocking the line disaster
cross-contaminated raw meat cooked meat
different foods [__] everywhere and then
the biggest asset where all the money is
is downstairs in the Y cellar
who's maintaining standards here he is I
cannot believe what you've just done in
there
I really enjoy it you can't enjoy that I
do that's I must be like cuckoo in the
headers well you need help maybe he does
you need to wake up
I think we can do this I know we can do
this yeah but not just you and you I
want to be you and I because you so
don't listen to me most of the time like
when I tell you it's time to come home
Jonathan it's time to [__] come to
bed and you just say [__] you no you
know [__] you now [__] you Jonathan oh
yeah I love you so much and you're such
a great guy but you suck as a business
partner you really suck thanks do you
want to recreate this you want to
clean clean I want to get divorced you
want to get divorced no I don't want to
get divorced why has it always been your
way because you know more than me
apparently I don't I'm as stupid as you
think I am if not worse
down fast enough
that looks pretty good all right
[Laughter]
candy okay
thanks for being on the other side we
appreciate it
oh sorry
that bourbon was really strong
crap
all right again it's not really crying
it's just releasing release it at least
you're gonna you and him together please
sure
I'm unconvinced and I've never met a
couple so undeserving of my time and I
think you Lisa you're just taking it
I'm just trying to no you're trying to
get through the night tonight no you're
acting the crocodile tears there next
man is a laugh it's self-preservation
and it's the only way for me to get
through the day there's no heart there's
no fear there's a lot of heart no
there's not I love what I do and what do
you love drinking with your friends I
don't do much drinking I'm not the party
girl he's the party boy so there's no
parties way on after service downstairs
in the basement with the customers not
in the past like 10 years
Jonathan you've lost interest
I'm a mess yeah you are
you supposed to do is
zag
I want you to get out of here
start packing
after sending Lisa and Jonathan away for
the night I'm hoping they can start to
realize the effects they are having on
the Vienna but before they return I
called a staff meeting morning good
morning good morning so I can get a
better understanding of the damage that
Lisa and Jonathan are doing
um I didn't get a chance to meet you
yesterday
um Jamie do the housekeeping here okay
great let's get one thing right I'm here
to help having done my research I mean
the one positive feedback I've had is
about how good the staff are because I
know you know just how bad things are
and having witnessed that service last
night uh I'm appalled is it always like
that yes
screaming yes
you can hear them in the dining room
I've had tables that have asked if
everything was okay in the kitchen we
can't be expected to be professional all
the time when they are not professional
after our Chef they'll sit down with the
table and expect us to wait on them hand
them drinks till midnight if we leave
they get upset so guests stay here and
they're drinking downstairs in front of
those guests sometimes with the guests
see there's no separation between
business right yeah and personal when
you're sitting here entertaining your
table she'll find something wrong that
you're doing and she'll come and point
it out at you right in front of your
table she's just rude she texts me
sometimes really rude text messages like
oh you forgot this or you forgot that or
why didn't you do this and why wasn't
this that's crazy another problem that
we've really been having is we don't
have an actual payroll system there's no
payroll system and then they'll say yeah
I'll get you one and you just never ask
him for your salary
yeah I got I got 20 bucks right now
that's all I got right now yeah tomorrow
morning I'll see you the drip feeding
your salaries my bank does not take the
checks neither does mine when was the
last time you had a staff meeting and
discussed this never never I'm sorry but
I want to put an end to all this is what
we're going to do
um they're arriving any minute now
and my message to them is if they're not
prepared to bring in a level of
professionalism and understand those
boundaries need to be met on a daily
basis they're going to lose the in and
they're going to lose you and we're
going to get them
[Music]
I let myself continue to be abused
rushed off any
[Music]
I had a chat with the team they're not
in a good place
and you've abused Them There Are No
Boundaries they're your staff and they
need to be treated
a certain way
let's go to Jamie first
I'm really concerned about the abusive
texts you send him why would you send
him an abusive text oh you would send me
a picture like oh you forgot this or you
didn't do this right or you told me that
you worked at a lot of other places and
you knew how to clean and then the
toilets aren't clean and stuff it's
really important but some of that stuff
doesn't work so it's like I'm sitting
there scrubbing and nothing's coming up
and you'll be like well go do it again
and it's like I'm trying I'm trying to
do what I can none of these Talent
individuals get paid on time
I want to know why they don't get paid
on time
because I don't have a payroll system in
place right now well that's a [__]
disgrace
that is disgusting
and then you want them waiting on you up
until all hours of the early morning
while they tidy up after your crap and
then you can't even be bothered to pay
them on time
it's a mess no you are a mess
I need to say something though that
almost every single person here we've
given them loans you're lending them
money to buy uniforms to work in your
goddamn business right that's absurd why
why I've served to pay for a uniform the
business should be providing the uniform
well maybe we need to do that I never
thought about it that way whose business
is this
I've tried to create here a place where
people can come
and and
relax and escape from their stressful
lives escape from their stressful lives
to hear you and Lisa scream at each
other
are you [__] kidding me
we don't always scream at each other but
when we do I'm that's why maybe I guess
the smallest places you live here so
you've got no idea how many times you do
it
the love affection and respect that
they've shown you is extraordinary
and the sad news is
you both don't deserve it
I'm sorry
I will change I just hope you guys want
to continue
I just want to say thank you for your
honesty uh loyalty uh there's some other
important people I want to introduce you
to this morning thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you guys
uh good morning ladies and gentlemen
good morning uh So Lisa and Jonathan uh
I've asked uh some ex-customers locals
to come and give you some feedback
has anybody stayed there recently we did
the room we stayed in it had tools and
screws and instruction manuals
so it's not just for the air
conditioners and stuff yeah that's right
you're right Madam give us an insight to
your experience please I do have to say
my husband ordered uh scallops and they
were Raw
we returned them the decor was very
outdated and it feels very cluttered you
feel like you're locked in a closet it's
just overwhelming when you're trying to
have a nice dinner I would never come
back there if things don't change
what do you guys think about the
uniforms it's a bit my poor ladies were
kind of revealing
the server was the nicest person but I
think it takes a lot away from them it
doesn't need to be in your face the
reputation locally
is crucial what have you guys heard I've
heard that's a swingers hang out
I heard that as well
when I had mentioned the Vienna they
said that's where the swingers go
you eat downstairs and then you go
upstairs is what I was told
but you've heard this before
we've heard it for 13 years but is this
due to your late night drinking and the
party I don't think so factor or not
that's how yeah you're living there but
what I'm trying to say is that there are
no boundaries it's a Oasis down there
that has got a Jacuzzi a massage table
and if the word has gotten out around
town
people misunderstood that room and
that's where it all started I'm just
saying it either a business
or it's your home there's no there's no
crossover the mixed messages you're
sending is your own fault because you
haven't been clear
I used to come to the restaurant
probably every month or so
and I can tell you have a lot of like
passion for your heritage but
it's not in the food anymore
if Gordon can help you take your
heritage and the food and modernize it
and you can progress with that I'll come
every Friday mark my words it's a
promise
do you have anything to say about you to
these yes thank you so much for your
honesty and input and
really really appreciate it we're going
to be making some big changes to uh
address many of the things you talked
about
the staff have been incredibly loyal
they have been treated the way they
should have been treated I'm undecided
about these two but I am committed to
that team because I see what is at stake
and the Jeopardy they face going forward
now
I got some something else important to
sort out
after leaving Jonathan Lisa I moved
forward with my plans to help renovate
the Inn I brought in Somalia Dave Foss
to create a beverage program if you just
have a look in here I mean that one's
fantastic from the excessive infantry
they weren't using oh three oh that's
delicious my team worked up to the last
minute transforming the many spaces at
the piano
Pole is holy smokes this is beautiful
this is incredible
Bravo
the Vienna had no Organization for
managing their day-to-day operations so
I gave him the state-of-the-art system
to help with all their hotel operational
needs welcome to the web res Pro system
and this will help transform your
business it will link up to the POS
system and it will give you data like
you've never had before that was you
need to be organized
from the Infantry to the wage costs to
the salaries to the PRS systems to the
checking in and the checking out system
and the good news guests can now book
online so this should relieve a huge
headache I could see that everyone was
thrilled with the changes at the Vienna
good have a good look around but as I
watch Lisa where's this stuff from
I noticed she was dissatisfied with the
renovations
and right now I'm worried where Lisa's
head is going in to relaunch this
evening
[Music]
good evening I can help you with your
bags of purse let's get you checked in
while it was time to relaunch the inn
and restaurants
yeah we have an artist I provided the
staff with brand new uniforms that go
with the new updated menu that includes
wine pairing and beer flights first is
going to be the grapefruit then the
second is going to be the pilsner
here Lisa off the line
actually let's turn this lamp on
no light bulb
oops
excuse me you see Jamie no light bulb in
there I just wanted to don't worry about
it
what who's complaining about the light
bulb just making sure that they have
enough light trying to turn it on then
realized it later it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter let's focus on the big
thingies are you always like this over
little details like that I like to have
things feel right and so I'm feeling
extra like an extra need to make sure
everything's right that's awesome
Ott
probably whatever
top
over the top I guess I don't have to be
so over the top now do I I do not yeah
what is wrong with her tonight do you
think she's gonna go back to her old
ways when I leave she
she accidentally customer's coming
welcome while Lisa is nitpicking
everything unnecessarily do you guys
have the appetizer for table five oh
sorry we didn't give you that yet no you
did it no no Jonathan is lost in the
kitchen and service is starting to
suffer what table number is this please
that is table number 11 and waiting on
the two flying Stakes with it now
where's the flank steak are they coming
uh Mormons moments uh minutes who's
cooking the flank steak come on guys we
can do one four top at the same time yes
yes I designed the menu around the size
of the kitchen the speed of both you
working together yep okay
where the hell is this
look at me both yes both you cut the
ship okay look at me you're more capable
of doing four [__] main courses at
the same time especially with the two of
you and one of those main courses is the
same dish we've got to talk to each
other but I'm not going to start selling
one dish at a time for a four top
serious it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter at all
Jonathan but look at me hey look at me I
need some [__] effort from you a
little bit I need a little bit of
respect and a little bit of effort from
you okay yeah and look at me yeah the
man holding this [__] thing together
you get it I do go down the whole
[__] place is going to go down so I
need you to step up okay I need to talk
a little bit I don't want four main
courses at the same [__] time
and Jonathan yeah you can get your mind
set round four main courses at the same
[__] time
understand we're serving one table at
time and we're gonna complete that table
yes four main courses three main courses
five main courses gonna talk together
yes perfect girls with work the two
soups what's coming next it's gonna be
uh sausage two carrot soups and a fried
cheese cheers for table seven okay so
we're talking now yep good okay thank
you very much we have your flank steaks
your wine is coming right away okay your
sausage you guys are all sharing right
yeah yeah I think the New Vienna will
definitely attract a younger crowd oh my
God so beautiful I'm super excited about
the new changes and I hope they'll last
I really do
uh right we've had ups and downs but
tonight is a prime example of how good
and how profitable this business can be
customers loving the food they love the
decor I'm leaving with all the tools to
get this place back to where you wanted
to go I do want to ask you one thing
sure is there anything that's happened
this week that you're not happy with yes
I had expected the blue men's room to be
done not the Konig but I was it was the
room I didn't expect and the room that
we've done is amazing it still has
problems can I just tell you something
really important this is not a makeover
show I know that yeah but you're
complaining about I wasn't saying I
didn't love that room it'd be a great
shame for you to sound ungrateful oh I'm
not ungrateful I am just sorry
definitely
it sounds like that
not at all I can't come in and wave a
magic one and transform 15 bedrooms and
put a brand new kitchen you now know
what needs to happen I do but I need to
tell you something that you're not gonna
like I arranged for a new stove you
didn't
to come and then when I got the engineer
to come and Survey the place
unfortunately he had to leave yeah
because he was going to shut the place
down
there's just practices that are taking
place in there that aren't appropriate
you're saying the whole setup underneath
there nothing's been changed in 13 years
and it's on the verge of
running legally okay
listen I came here to help but you need
to help yourselves and you have to dig
deep and stick together okay
thank you thank you good luck okay keep
going okay good night thank you
safe traveling
soon after I left Lisa and Jonathan
reverted to the old Vienna this is
something that belongs here that came
with the house
what are you doing you're insane by
changing the decor and bringing back the
original menu it's worse than it was it
looks horrible they chose not to take my
advice about running the Inn properly
listen to me about what should be going
on in the kitchen and as a result their
reputation in town Remains the Same
foreign
[Music]
lies the borough of Newtown Pennsylvania
home to this historic brick Hotel
owner Veranda Kwa a former therapist
bought the property in 2006 with her son
CJ who serves as a silent partner in
their business
we bought the brick Hotel because it was
an investment opportunity when we first
purchased the place we were told that it
was going to be a sort of a hands-off
it'll run itself you just have to watch
it of course we had no idea
zero idea what this business is about
I always said to my son maybe this year
we'll make a profit maybe this year will
make a profit and it never happened she
used to be in Family Therapy so patience
comes with that job and I've seen her
have a short fuse where she wouldn't do
that before we bought the place when I
came here it blew my mind away that
you're still putting in money so I cut
out a lot of stuff here and it really
annoyed and irritated people and they
basically started the dislike render
plan
[Music]
has been a bit of a dictatorship here
with verandar you know it's either her
way or not her way no no
no no verandar is a control freak she is
involved in everything she will not
release or relinquish
control ever here's the ball do you want
me to put it in she's not a people
person she has no people skills
she just screams out demands and she's
very rude at times
French onion on here now there is such a
turnover with staff that I don't even
know their names in eight months I've
probably seen over 50 people go some
people come in for one shift and they
listen to her for five minutes and they
roll right out the door
me this place
I feel that Brooke might have become
like the laughing stock of Newtown
so the repetition around town is that
you know no non so they call me the
crazy lady which is fine to me you know
what if I'm crazy because I'm trying to
save the business so be it I think we're
at that point where this is really our
last chance if we don't figure something
out it's either sell it get rid of it
because we can't sustain it
[Music]
before I came to town I heard the brick
Hotel had a high ton of a rate so I had
my team reach out to former employees so
I can get some information before
checking in uh
morning I've never met such a large team
of ex-employees
this is a small showing oh yeah what
there's more
hydrants
I would say hundreds um how much
turnover is there with staff so when I
left I've been through almost 50
managers 15.
50 managers 50.
and the biggest problem with the place
is what
verandor
I watched her and she's
and she can be a bully and
you know reduce people to tears wow
that's terrible
you know there's so much neglect between
not only the staff or managers but her
customers as well seriously
I couldn't take it anymore I worked the
holiday season and it was kind of like
the last straw for me and what made you
quit I worked all of those parties
through the whole month of December I
was lucky to receive some payback like
in February with your tips yeah she'll
cut you a check in six weeks when she
feels like it she wouldn't let you go
pick up your paycheck she called the
cops on you
you said she called the cops on you
numerous times seriously call the police
because you wanted your money yes you're
threatening her yeah seriously I mean it
sounds like a dictatorship as opposed to
a boss that's there to support people
loved it there it was very Homey the
opposite of now all the locals came we
had a booming Hotel business wow it was
such a great place and then the quality
just steadily went downhill and I think
she had a complete lack of respect for
the staff and didn't understand that
your staff is a huge asset
I was curious just by the way you were
speaking because I thought he hasn't met
her yet has he no no no so calling the
cops you know hi staff turnover
um standards dropping I haven't got much
confidence however I'm gonna tackle it
head on
and you don't look very optimistic do
you
think thank you wish me luck
take care
[Music]
wow look at the size of this place
oh dear
what happened there
damn
when did that happen you know it's been
here since I've been here oh really hi
I'm Marianne this place is good to see
you I get a bit nervous when I check
into a hotel the windows are smashed
uh anyway how are you I'm good thank you
I'm happy to be here
play bullet holes in the wall oh you
know they might very well be I'm not
sure what they are we're 250 years old
so 250 years old
what's wrong with the place I think it's
a beautiful place but I think it really
just needs some
upgrading and which part of peaceful
help me
selling up the entrance with the smash
Windows well I think
could be beautiful yes been neglected
for a while
what happened here
oh
oh my
God
that looks much better wow zero yeah I
don't know foreign
hi
how are you good how are you yeah very
well a little bit nervous for smashed
glass what happened there
it's been there since before I bought it
uh yeah how long we have the hotel 10
years 10 years and you didn't think
about replacing it first impressions
customers walked through the door it's
it's original have you been drinking
before we bought this 10 years ago yeah
never never now what did you do
therapists for children
I did that for 20 years that was my
practice
wow okay uh 201 I'll see you uh shortly
I'm gonna check in and uh unpack okay
Marianne I need a rag uh napkin or
housekeeping please
whoa
[Music]
what is that oh
Jesus let me get housekeeping for you
housekeeping caught fire brigade
hello are you the housekeeper I'm not
I'm looking for I'm Caitlyn please me so
my hands are dirty so I'm just kidding
me I don't want to shake hands like that
sure no when was the last time this
place was cleaned there's dust and [__]
everywhere uh delay is here every day uh
so I would assume Right cleaning I mean
under here look I'm not talking about a
couple of weeks of dust I'm talking
years I'm behind here as well look
hi oh
geez how are you hi are you good yes I'm
fine fine right what do you do
housekeeping stop which house
this house come over look at the mess
down there what's that what's that
let's get the place clean fabulous let's
just have a little test here
look at that
look at that do you have a program that
you clean floor by floor
a program
no no
uh where is my room
your room now what's that up there
who sits here
is it a [__] tea party for rats or
Stuart Little in for dinner tonight what
the [__] is that
oh what is it like pet corner
we drop our cats off for dinner here
man who does this you care to join me
come on
go foreign
let's talk about your cleaning habits
my butt's way bigger than yours so take
a seat
now we have some menus please ah sure
yeah absolutely so what in the [__] is
going on
I actually said something about that but
you know
you comfy
absolutely not no
all jokes apart forget the mice party
tea parties too little [__] hang out
what is the biggest problems here
because I'm not like this
oh
we got rid of the Dust what do you mean
the mold where's the mold oh right yeah
take me to the mall okay thank you let's
start this way but where let's go this
way
mold
I guess it starts I don't know exactly
where it comes but it comes from
somewhere on a shower curtains I
actually come with changes did you tell
the owner to change these apps yes sir
and any response she'll get to it oh
look at this
look at that come over
is there more that is mold yes I said
that that's most
how when was all the linen last changed
look at the color of this
how much sweat is on there oh man
oh look at the color of that so that's
what that is sweats that's sweat and
then is that is that a tube television
how old
have you ever heard of a flat screen
yeah I got five you've got five flat
screens at my house
what a mess what's that in there
what
a empty box of tights silk Perfections
does the owner ever come into these
rooms since I've been here I've probably
seen her here maybe once once upon a
time these were white right you see
these look at the color of them
how gray and dirty God they stink oh you
can tell they're supposed to be white oh
man I was worried about your eyes for a
second uh where's my room please
201 please tell me it's not worse than
this one
bloody how
what a mess dust everywhere and all this
what is this
terrible
girl how you doing I found all the nasty
no no I thought that the curtains were
gold duh
no
for real they were supposed to be white
oh my goodness I am appalled
just underneath the old one
right now it's pretty obvious that
the owner
doesn't even put a scent back into this
room even to the hotel
but
when an owner can't be bothered to
change a smash window and reception
I don't hold much hope for the rest of
the hotel and look at that up there
what's that check out time 11 A.M you
know I'll check out way before that my
love
[Music]
hi nice to meet you I'm Tammy Gordon
good to see you good to meet you
um and your sales and event coordinator
at The Brick rumors has it you do a lot
of events do a lot of events how many a
week on average about 350 a year it
sounds like this is the oxygen that's
keeping this place alive unfortunately
that's the truth wow what other problems
are there help me our staffing is
terrible why there's so many staff going
through the door what is it we're around
our inspiring them often I'll come in on
Monday and see who didn't make it
through the weekend she's very tough to
work for the bottom line is the problem
is the owner yes there's nobody else
here starts at the top I appreciate you
honestly well we appreciate you being
here after learning the hotel's revenue
is strictly from events I want to see
how bad the food really is seasonal
local fresh I ordered a couple of items
the French onion soup which was
tasteless that's so bad terrible
so I opted for something with a little
more flavor
that tastes better
then I ordered something I'd never heard
of before a cauliflower steak which by
name I should have known better that is
a mess I've put it on the menu Miranda
and a crab sandwich which maybe I would
expect to be Frozen but not from a can
Product of China
seriously are we done is it you've got
your burger still do you know what
cancel it absolutely because if it's
coming from the same kitchen forget it
got it yeah tell the chef I travel light
and I haven't got that many [__]
pairs of knickers thank you oh my gosh
oh my gosh
cancel everything else
no more no more you said enough
[Music]
uh take me to the kitchen introduce me
to the team
place is huge
kitchen is massive
uh so where's the chef hello
you're not the chef you are a chef
though you got a jacket on yes sir
that's how Chef tend to dress Maceo it's
good to meet you too and this is very
very sexy buried so you get it you're
the chef I'm not this Chef no you're the
chef egg chef but not Fisher there's two
of them there's two of them the other
ones uh where's the head chef well we
have both of them in charge no such
thing your set of rules your set of
rules doesn't benefit the castles I'll
come back to the food in a minute I'm in
shock
before I got here I met a dozen of your
ex-employees
that I couldn't believe the amount of
staff that have left this building in
the last two years why are you going
through so many staff I don't know you
don't know I think I hire people and uh
oh so it's them not good enough for you
so yes
yeah
when you
have a young member of staff that is
owed money
and they won't leave the building until
you pay them and you call the police on
them what kind of business are you
running here
who said that are you saying now that
they're lying
please I don't know are you saying
they're lying simple yes or no I cannot
tell people you cannot say it's
inaccurate though it's inaccurate yes
I have witnessed verandar called the
cops on a number of people she has a
close relationship with the Newtown
Police Department
care about this hotel
it's not funny I mean I am not here to
laugh let's get that right
let's move on to my reception when I
walked in and there's dust and [__]
everywhere when I say dust I'm talking
dust that's been embedded for years
and there's mold on the carpet I'm a
little bit loss of words I ever sat down
in the restaurant and had dinner right
top of your menu it's fresh
seasonal local it's canned foods I'm not
a chef and I don't know all these things
what's wrong you're feeling sick no I
need to take something out of the oven
so you take it out the oven what is this
tomorrow's chicken
I see you laugh
what is this
a game you have to [__] wake up
hi hey guys how are you
excited yes we're checking in
no problem
bye bye
how are you Hi how are you nice to meet
you I'm Jessica Jessica good to see you
I heard you had a great time today great
time not but uh yeah let's wait and see
yeah who's that that is CJ that is our
son oh hi CJ yes one of the co-owners as
well good to me how many times what you
had I'm here right now probably less
than once a month even
I've got another job that I pretty much
a full-time would you do uh manage I.T I
see why did you buy this why did we buy
this it was an investment opportunity
when we first got into it we're told
that it was TurnKey hands off so that
was 10 years ago yes have you seen any
return on that yet zero zero when do you
think it's coming uh
I have been talking about that quite a
bit over the last six months because
it's getting difficult to keep putting
money in wow in your mind
forget him what's wrong with the place
I'm very sorry because I know this is
your mom but I can't I can't deal with
how she treats me it's like when we
don't need her here she's here and she's
on me about the smallest things wow
do you have one foot in their camp or
one foot in your mother's Camp
um
I'm split between the two I've actually
had employees tell me why aren't you
around more because you're Pleasant to
deal with how's this going to get turned
around if she's still micromanaging and
dictating to everybody about how this
place should be run
she says if she's not here it's things
will fall apart and it won't get done
that sounds right
I know his customers hi guys how are you
good evening good how are you welcome
how are you you're welcome you guys have
a reservation yeah Weinstein sorry about
the smash window
and the crowd's from China because from
China okay you guys can follow me
I don't go to China for crap
[Music]
your gentlemen I have one order for you
it's just the first course on the first
table it's just two stupid days
thank you
okay who's next
[Music]
I got all the suits all right first
thing is this it's a apple pear Nobles
blue cheese
and an eggplant stack
where's the apple pear can we get this
out
why is she doing this is she always on
the hot plate she is she's never quiet
which ones are done can you guys take
those down is this done
I have taken my stuff down that's done
yeah wow
guys
it's coming for window it's coming we're
working it hard it's making us nervous
oh my goodness Harley Carly
what I'm coming what is that put this
here take this this is yours no that is
my New York style this is craziness
who's drawing the cauliflower
are you cooking the cauliflower now
yes
I know
can you flip this
and what you do cooking I have no idea
you should normally cook yeah this is
crazy absolutely crazy
[Music]
what a mess
wheels are stuck just sliding on the
[__] Grease
oh God
it's gross
Brenda you got two seconds sure just
stand behind there oh my goodness please
stand behind there I'm I'm
what is this
missio you guys just cleaned this is
this from today
I don't even know what's back there
verinder what
when was that cleaned it's they just
think of two days ago they just spilled
everything there come here
I know hand on heart that is not from
yesterday
what's that up there seriously watch
your eyes watch your eyes
who cleans this [__]
who is it because I've been here no
one's cleaned it since you've been here
no one's cleaning I appreciate your
honesty
Brenda yeah
[Music]
since he's been here he's never cleaned
it
this place is disgusting
this
well I'm recording I don't come and do
this I trust them that they would clean
where they are
you you guys cleaned the floor the other
day didn't you we cleaned the line the
other day we sweeped the line you said
you guys took out no I never said that
you're just trying to make excuses yes
you are
you embarrassed very at least you taught
the [__] truth the owner's in denial
that has been pulled out for [__]
months that wasn't pulled out
what a [__] mess
what is this
holy crap
in there oh my God what in the [__] is
that
yours what in the [__] is that that's
grease from the hood
can you stop lying
that was not cleaned yesterday I'm
telling you this is Greece from the hood
but they haven't cleaned it do you have
any idea what happened if that caught
fire
now do you have any idea if that caught
I do what are you doing
you stopped caring
no that's not true I mean that's the
sign of an owner that cares
I want an answer I'm going upstairs by
the time I come down I want an answer
CJ is he gone I don't know where he went
oh my God
right
I'm convinced that this place is clean
so I want to run a quick bacteria test
it looks disgusting but I don't think
these vents have been cleaned for years
timer
did you talk to Ramsay no he came down
here looking for you
now 10 to 20 is deemed as sort of clean
respectable anything over 30 is
unhygienic
dangerous and this is reading
[Music]
573.
come in you were looking for me uh sit
down what is that this is a very simple
hygiene test
anything above 30 is in the danger zone
okay
573 from the air conditioning unit
I don't have an answer for that sorry
that's
CJ
573. let's do another one how long has
this chair been here but I believe since
we bought the place have you seen the
stains on it
see the stains there yeah
stay here uh no I've never stayed here
you've never stayed here in 10 years no
wow so you bought a hotel you invested
in it with mum and you've never stayed
here
I'm Amazed
446.
and you've got no idea it's like this
what's the bathrooms like oh my God
[Music]
do you know the shower curtains got mold
on them no I do not your housekeeper
pointed it out
at this rate I really should be wearing
gloves oh dear
a shower cut
[Music]
what 5 680 what in the [__]
seriously
I I don't have an answer for that at all
five thousand six hundred and eighty
that is the volume of live bacteria
I'm gonna wash my hands [__] hell
five thousand what
is going on
I'm gonna go and just check 301.
sorry are you well I'm so sorry do you
mind listen we've got some issues
downstairs I found some pretty horrific
stuff I know you're getting ready for
bed I'm sorry
I honestly didn't think they're gonna
put anyone in here today
it's mold underneath
that is disgusting and I did a bacteria
test I've been doing them all day on my
shower curtain was mold
just took a shower
we just give me two minutes okay oh my
God
[Music]
let's go come on let's go oh no oh my
God baby back's dad make your way down
to the front please leave the phone it's
not important customers are way more
important leave the phone
customers out customers out let's go out
Barry drop what you're doing go off the
premise for you we're not gonna be
serving this anyway quick let's go we've
got to move fast on that let's go never
extend to the front just wait two
seconds is everyone out this is in the
drill oh my God
first of all I just want to apologize
there's no fire
more importantly over the last three
hours all I've done is a bacteria test
I want to apologize to all of you but I
want to stop right now while I try
endlessly to get through the owner who's
totally oblivious
this is the owner we all ain't here we
were all playing on stay here and you're
smiling like a smirk on your face
what I'm not going to do is just allow
this lady to laugh at me you guys to pay
good money and eat and I'm certainly not
letting paying gas stay to sleep here
I'm done my team will assist you getting
yourself out of there relax there is no
fire but we are not going to continue I
want to stop right now and shut this
place down
[Music]
I'm so sorry
I need you now
thank you
[Music]
when are you gonna get real
when are you going to stop close the
[__] door and take a good look at
yourself in the mirror if I say anything
it's not believed so what's the point
what do you mean it's not believed what
is wrong with you well I can what is
wrong with you what is wrong with you
there's nothing wrong with me it's just
after 10 years I'm here every single day
they don't like me and they insult me
and they disrespect me every second they
work here they steal from me they're on
their cell phones for four hours a day
you're disrespecting every member of
staff you're blaming everybody for what
you've created somewhere you switched
off and ignored all the problems and
took out on the staff that's what
they're telling you yes that's what
they're telling me right now I'm going
to tell you something you've never heard
before
you're at your depth
foreign
[Music]
last night after shutting down the hotel
and seeing Veranda had no communication
with employees I organized a staff
meeting anyone down there
but Veranda was nowhere to be found
there you are there I've been looking
for you
they said that you'd ran away
you don't want to be in front of the
staff why not
my biggest problem is that you have shut
down and you refuse to let anybody in I
walked through the windows people steal
from me every single day and so you had
some incidents with some bad staff years
ago and then you think everybody that
comes through your door is it is exactly
the same no they're not it's not about a
one-on-one anymore you can't just focus
on one individual and you've done that
brilliantly in the previous career
running a team managing hotel is
completely different we need to get the
team back on side and they need to
believe in you and you need to believe
in them it's a two-way thing well it's a
process too
it is a process
but if you don't walk back through those
doors and face the music
with me then I'm gonna go as well
because I can't do this without you I
don't know how let me show you how
[Music]
uh well first of all
um thanks for coming in early this
morning
um listen this is hard
there seems to be a massive conflict
how do we get the trust back in the room
what would you like to see change
we just did a funeral last week 90
people and there was two servers zero
Busters zero bartender well of course
it's a money issue it's a budget issue
so I took it over and that is why we had
a schedule on Monday for the cooks
we come back Tuesday the schedule's
completely changed you do the schedule
but there should be the chef's job
absolutely you need to be responsible
for your own departments I mean like
Macy's responsible for the kitchen
Tammy's responsible for the events you
have to offload the work from you and
give them the responsibility I guess
that's a mistake
when was the last time you had a meeting
we had a service staff meeting in here
that we get yelled at and it just gets
hostile and people get up and me include
it and walk out and
it just doesn't help anything let's stop
there this is why this is why no one
wants to no one ever yeah
you must understand now that's the wrong
way to handle things
there seems to be a really bad vibe in
the room that we can't shake off
but if you want to clear the air people
need to turn their phones off when they
walk in and clock in can I say something
about the phone I have said that million
times please do not bring your cell
phones in here and invariably I come in
at two o'clock I see you guys outside on
your cell phones if that is a break it's
never seen you myself okay fine I mean
you know maybe you're not doing it but
other people are doing it
Why is the
so much distrust in this building
people
drinking on the job doing shots over
here that's not now we're talking as if
it's present yes but there is I mean you
know these guys aren't taking shots
but what I'm trying to say you're you're
accusing them of somebody else's bad
practices
what you need to stop doing is blaming
them for the past
can you trust your team
tell them that okay I'll try please I
can't I can promise wow I can only try
look at that smile that'll go a long way
we all know it's not going to change
overnight it's the process
so we need to embrace that process and
we need to install confidence
me too
follow
ing to make this place a success
I feel like the staff meeting was a step
in the right direction
Verandas seems to be coming around but I
want to make sure she is 100 committed
morning uh thanks so much for coming I
really need to talk to CJ privately
because he's the one person who can help
get through to her
thank you
uh CJ I'm gonna be honest I'm gonna be
up front I'm not dealing with a hotelier
I'm dealing with your mum and I'm sure
she holds a special place in your heart
but unfortunately she's running around
like a dictator and she's not letting
any of the staff breathe she's stifling
the business I've had conversations with
her about a few things similarly I've
told her
um the way we were brought up and raised
in India that tone in conversation
doesn't work here and she struggled to
be very honest adapting to that part of
it um you adapted brilliantly come to
this country but she's one tough cookie
you know that yeah she is nitpicking the
staff and then she's not giving any of
them responsibility she needs to be less
Hands-On okay and more supportive no I
know I know
this is crazy mid 60s she shouldn't be
running around like this no she was very
honest with me last week she told me I
want to spend more time with the kids
and my time is running out and I haven't
heard her say that ever all right but
she needs to let go okay
so how can I help I need a commitment
from you got to be there to support it
we need to get rid of that stubbornness
from your mum and make you understand
that this business can be fruitful she
just has to step back okay we can't
continue like this is do or die and we
need to step up okay all right I'm gonna
have a talk with her today please
we got one more shot at this
after spending time with CJ he clearly
sees the issues his mother has and I
have asked him to reinforce the changes
she needs to make what we should talk
about is how do you let go
the responsibility is shifting which
means you don't run around doing things
if it's Michelle's kitchen if you're
making that decision if not your problem
to deal with let Jeremy and the kitchen
Chef do everything
I learned it the hard way at my job I
was working 70 hours a week mother yeah
but when I got the team in place and I
stepped away
I only get involved when there's an
escalation okay
all right I mean you know I can do that
and you know what let's see what happens
it's Veranda on the right track the next
order of business is starting the
renovation process the brick Hotel
needed drastic changes so my team worked
through the night to get the hotel ready
for relaunch welcome to the new brick
Inn wow
[Music]
wow
oh my goodness it's amazing
it is
you'd like to come up and see my room
yes yes
[Music]
wow oh my gosh I'm about to take a nap
I'll take it to that I think I might
have to come check it out
everything about these rooms are amazing
wow I'm excited to come to work and
clean come over to jump on them
oh my goodness very nice thank you so
much
after updating the brick hotel with a
modern look I give them a classic menu
that is perfect for the town I can
better accommodate catering with a
large-scale events that take place at
the hotel hi good evening welcome to the
brick Hotel as for the relaunch I
invited the locals not only to dine at
the bridge how were the first couple
bites of everything oh fantastic
it's all the renovated rooms as well oh
Mike look at this oh my god look how
nice this is
ah
Hotel side everything has been well
received the kitchen is running smoother
than ever meatballs arancini Sprouts
Japanese yes
86 fossil Sprouts please that's a good
sign thank you and with CJ having a
presence brussels sprouts
what do you mean go get them he's able
to prevent his mother from slipping back
into her old habits okay you said it's a
good sign
yeah
now she can focus on her duties as an
owner looks fantastic
customers are happy yes yes first of all
it's so nice to see you smile yeah she
had to walk around this town with your
head up high well I apologize for the
difficulty I gave you initially okay and
anything I want to see you do is
time to time come in here and walk
around like you did all night tonight
with charm and Grace I've told them that
you are banned from behind that line
okay okay all right I promise you all
this stuff will happen
promise me yes
I'm not a person who expresses Joy or
you know you know jumping up and down
and things like that but it's really
really wonderful it's given us a lot of
oxygen for a second life best wishes
okay take care thank you
wow what a week
[Music]
after leaving the brick the reputation
of the hotel was on the mend CJ became a
more visible owner and Veranda stayed
true to her word in trusting her staff
to do their jobs and her employee
turnover is at an all-time low with
these changes in place the brick is well
on its way to being what it once was
[Music]
oh